ce plan national de restructuration des
centres afpa en charge vous le savez de
la formation professionnelle pour
adultes
un projet qui pourrait se traduire par
la fermeture pure et simple du centre de
nevers et le transfert des activités du
creusot et de quétigny vers d'autres
sites bourguignons
le point sur cette affaire avec marilyn
baratte fanny borius tanya gomez et
quant à césar en bourgogne franche comté
plus de 9000 adultes dont la moitié de
demandeurs d'emploi se forme chaque
année à l'afpa c'est le cas de cette
nouvelle promotion maintenance chauffage
et climatisation
ils sont partis pour un cursus de neuf
mois sur le site de chevigny saint
sauveur avec à la clé une certification
une opportunité que romain ne voulait
pas rater je me suis renseigné déjà
autour de moi parce qu'il manquait de
l'expérience en tant que dépanneur tout
ce qui est dépannage en show est en
froid donc
des connaissances ma boîte d'intérim
pôle emploi et puis voilà pilaf pages
déjà fait une formation donc le chèque
c'est une bonne école mais cet acteur
majeur de la formation professionnelle
pour adultes traverse une crise la
semaine dernière un projet national de
restructuration a été présenté en
bourgogne il prévoit de supprimer les
centres afpa de nevers du creusot et de
quetigny pour ces deux derniers sites
les formations seraient transférés vers
des centres voisins et c'est une
situation qu'on retrouve dans toutes les
régions
la seule réponse selon la direction pour
faire face 70 millions d'euros de
déficit qui s'est instaurée depuis
l'ouverture du secteur à la concurrence
le modèle ne l'a pas il était basé il ya
une dizaine d'années sur un modèle de
subventions et effectivement le passage
de cette subvention sur des marchés ne
s'est pas fait naturellement
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup de
mal à voir comment l'afpa le bourgogne
franche comté va pouvoir rebondir avec
quatre centres de formation à -62 postes
en moins pour 50 pourtant ce sont
essentiellement des formateurs et nous
allons donc perdre environ 39 la
technique la casse d'un outil au service
des demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi une
casse sociale dans leurs rangs voilà ce
que dénoncent les syndicats qui
organisent une assemblée générale demain
dans le centre de nevers le site
bourguignon le plus impacté